all right um let's go to five headlines
[Music]
today's five headlines brought to you by
the benham brothers learn how to own a
business without it owning you get a 15
discount on the benham brothers new
course expert ownership at
benhambrothers.com
walsh number one 15 people were um
shot while leaving a funeral in chicago
yesterday
here's the the local report on that
chicago police telling us that there
were 14
gunshot victims in this one incident
that happened near 79th and carpenter
here in the auburn gresham neighborhood
tonight the shooting actually happened
outside of a funeral home as a group was
exiting that funeral home
a car drove by and started firing at
that group
we are learning more about the person
being remembered it was a service for
donny weathersby he was 31 years old he
was shot in the head a week ago
in englewood again this happened around
6 30 tonight chicago police telling us
it was that black car that drove by the
funeral home
on 79th and passed by that funeral home
firing shots into a crowd again 14
people were shot
but chicago police say they found 60
shell casings
on scene and that was because the crowd
actually started firing back
at the occupants in that car chicago
police believe there may have been four
occupants in that car
they say that they do believe that they
have one person of interest
in custody so just another day in
chicago really i guess
that's what it's like in the city in
many cities chicago especially but
chicago's mayor lori lightfoot she says
that the citizens of her city
you know they're not really worried
about this about armed men
gunning them down in mass while they're
walking down the street they're not
worried about that
what they're worried about are the
federal law enforcement officers that
trump has sent
into portland um to take control
and really specifically to defend the
federal building there
that the angry mob has repeatedly tried
to burn down
we're told somehow this is a very
unreasonable step by the president
to try to prevent the mob from burning
down a federal building how dare you you
tyrant
here's the tweet that lori lightfoot
sent out on the same night that over a
dozen people were sprayed with bullets
in her city
she says under no circumstances why
allow donald trump's troops to come to
chicago and terrorize our residents
yes terrorize our residents you really
think
lightfoot you incompetent ridiculous
hack
you think that's what your residents are
terrified by
when they're walking down the street you
think they're worried about
a federal agent coming coming and
shooting them
no they're they're worried about what
happened to those people leaving the
funeral
just got randomly shot this is happening
every day in your godforsaken
hellhole of a city that's what they're
terrified of and terrorized by
number two ringo checking in ayanna
presley sent out this tweet
says cancel rent cancel mortgage cancel
student debt
86 000 likes on that doesn't take a lot
of effort for the left
for leftist politicians um and yeah i
like it too
i'm going to add we'll make it 86 0001
likes because i
like it only i prefer to add to it you
know let's like
yeah cancel all those let's also cancel
while we're at it um sadness
loneliness tummy aches
diabetes death that's a big one
uh asteroids the law of cause and effect
you know it's to me really
harsh is my buzz i don't know about you
gravity
canceled so we can fly obviously um
and you know why not cancel war and
hunger while we're at it
we might as well i can't believe no
one's thought of that by now
like that that's quite an oversight so
cancel all the bad things
here's the point and this is and this is
what ayanna presley is trying to say and
it's really quite brilliant
what she's saying is cancel the bad
things right now listen to this listen
to the next part though okay
cancel the bad things all right step one
step two have only
good things you see that
really um i mean just incredible
insight brilliant strategy and this is
why we need people like ayanna presley
in congress
with those kinds of ideas number three
twitter's cracking down on accounts and
groups that are dangerous
which is good because you know i can
think of some dangerous groups that are
right now in the process of ripping
american cities to shreds
you know that uh that that would be
maybe a
a group you want to keep an eye on if
your twitter or any other social media
they do use these social media platforms
to organize
and plan their um felonious activities
so
i could understand twitter cracking down
on them but only of course twitter is
not worried about those groups instead
they're targeting
the cuanon people here's the
announcement from twitter
and a long thread they said we've been
clear that we will take strong
enforcement action on behavior that has
but the potential to lead to offline
harm
in line with this approach this week we
are taking further action on so-called
q anon activity across the service
we will permanently suspend accounts
tweeting about these topics that we know
are engaged in violations of our
multi-account
policy coordinating abuse around
individual victims or are attempting to
evade
previous suspensions something we've
seen more of in recent weeks um
and then it uh goes on from there
let me just say aside from the obvious
absurdity of going after
q anon uh when you've got antifa using
your platform to plan
violent activity aside from that
if you're trying to tamp down a
conspiracy theory especially conspiracy
theory like q anon
this is not the way to do it this is
actually the opposite of how you do it
i could think of no better way of
of in the minds of q anon people
confirming
everything they think than by banning
them in mass
first of all acknowledging them by name
so it's not even just that twitter
saying conspiracy theorists it's
q anon people that's what they're saying
acknowledge it by name and say we are
targeting them for suspension
in the mind of a conspiracy theorist you
have just like if somebody was
toying with the q anon idea if they were
on the verge
if they were on the gateway of being a q
a on conspiracy theorists you have just
shoved them all the way over the edge
with this
um which if i want to be conspiratorial
myself i almost think that's part of the
point
for twitter and other platforms they
want
more people on the right to buy into
this q anon
idiocy because it makes us look so
stupid and it discredits us
so they like it and they're going to do
anything they can to encourage it if i
wanted to be conspiratorial myself i
would say that maybe that's the point
here
number four um okay let me read this to
you this is good
uh always good to be alerted when some
new thing becomes racist you got to keep
up on this
and there's a new thing becoming racist
every day so it's really important
uh what i actually do is i have a
an alert on my phone and i have it say
there's an actually
an app you could get and anytime a new
thing becomes racist it'll send you an
alert and i can just check
oh this is racist now and i can just you
know i'll pick up my phone
um even a couple mornings ago i picked
up my phone alert
it says pancakes are racist and i
thought okay good
because i was gonna have pancakes for
breakfast they're racist now i'll go
with waffles
um all right so this is the latest thing
actually that app doesn't exist but
someone needs to make that app i throw
that idea
out there actually i don't throw it out
i retract it because i might want to do
that myself
don't do it you can't legally i've just
copyrighted it all right
this is how it works uh let's go to uh
okay
where was this which which ridiculous
publication huffington post all right
uh it says if a research group today
conducted a study on a single gender or
ethnic group critics would be quick to
point out
that its findings couldn't reasonably be
applied to anyone outside of that group
or gender
it seems like basic logic right
unfortunately such is the case with the
body mass index
a weight to height ratio used by health
care providers insurance companies and
the scientific community
there is growing consider criticism for
the use of bni bmi for example it
doesn't take
body composition fat versus muscle into
account
and a person's weight doesn't correlate
directly with their health
however there's not much mainstream
discussion about his racist roots
and then okay let me get to the part
because this is what matters
they're saying bmi is they start by
saying bmi is
is not a great way of actually measuring
whether or not someone is fat
overweight or or unhealthy i actually
agree with that
i think it's not good i i think it's i
think it is a
not a very effective tool in that way
but they also claim that it's racist so
let's go this is where they explain
the racist roots of the body mass index
the racist roots of the body the bmi
index
go back a long way created by belgian
mathematician adolfe
quitolet in 1832 as the quetilet index
the scale was created i think we should
still call it the quettale
index it's more fun to say the scale was
created using data from predominantly
european men to measure weights in
different populations
although quite a lot noted that it was a
population level tool and not meant to
be used on individuals
physiologists ansel keyes reintroduced
the calculation into
1972 as the body mass index
um so that's it
those are the racist routes if you were
waiting for something else i was too
that that's it that's the whole that's
why it's racist is because
it was used um for the data they
originally used a lot of european men
that makes it racist like it's some sort
of conspiracy against black people
uh but this is of course everything has
to be right on the left now they can't
just
merely criticize something it has to
also be racist
which in this case is completely
pointless as it often is because
you can easily make the case if you have
a problem with the bmi index you can
easily make the case
on a scientific level we don't need to
get into
it's somehow bmi somehow a body mass
index is racist that's absurd but when
do you get into that
there are many solid scientific reasons
or a lot of health experts who would
tell you
that this is not a very effective way of
measuring whether or not someone is
really healthy or not
uh and i agree with that maybe i'm
you know and maybe it's a little bit
selfish on on my part because
you know i've looked at bmi indexes and
that sort of thing before
and then try to calculate where i am am
i overweight
and oftentimes on those things they'll
tell me that i'm overweight i don't feel
like i'm over i don't think i look
overweight maybe i do
it's possible but i don't think that i
am so maybe there's a little bit of
you know maybe it's a little bit
self-serving on my part but uh i don't
think it always takes into account every
everything that needs to be taken into
account all right um let's go to
number five easy transition here from
huffington post
to teen vogue um
and you know what i was gonna read from
this but i've done too much reading
already and i can't even
the title the the headline is black
power naps
is addressing systemic racism in sleep
i can't even stomach i i'm sorry i was
going to read some of this
i'm sure it's pretty funny what they're
claiming is that
well it's just right there there's
systemic racism in sleep now
sleep itself is systemically racist
and they actually call for the writer of
this article uh brittany
mcnamara at some point let me see if i
can at least find this part
at some point she talks about
sleep reparations that are needed
we need to have on top of regular
reparations money
there also need to be sleep reparations
i'm not sure exactly how that will work
um you know i kind of feel like you know
if you're a black person you want to
take a nap go take a nap
i i don't think you need specific
reparations here just like anybody else
if you want to take a nap you could
probably carve out some time in the day
to do
it uh not much of a napper myself but
anyway all right i'm not even gonna
sorry i can't
i can't do you can go to teen vogue
yourself and read that article if you
want to
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative
outlets in the entire country if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
like and then subscribe to our youtube
channel so you don't miss out on any of
our content